"A Midwinter's Tale" is an intriguing standalone
solstice story that also offers a sneak peek
at what we can look forward to in Season 2
of Chilling Adventures of Sabrina.
Spoilers ahead…
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm breaking down the seven biggest
Season 2 reveals from A Midwinter's Tale and
explaining what those Three Demon Kings are
really up to in Greendale!
Let's begin with Letitia, which we learn is
the name Zelda has given to the baby girl
that she stole away from Father Blackwood.
At the end of the holiday episode, Zelda explains
that after what happened with Gryla, she feels
it won't be possible to keep the baby girl
hidden from Blackwood in the Spellman house.
So, her plan is to take Letitia to Dezmelda
who she says "will raise her in seclusion,
teaching her the old ways, as is her birthright."
Dezmelda previously appeared in the Feast
of Feasts episode of season 1.
She's an excommunicated witch who lives alone
in the woods and who Sabrina, Ms Wardwell
and the Weird Sisters visited when they were
finding out more about the history of the
Feast of Feasts.
Dezmelda actually has her own history with
the High Priest of the Church of Night, as
she was selected as the queen for the cannibalistic
feast when she was a child, but she fled for
her own safety when she learned the high priest
planned to violate her as part of an initiation
for the ritual.
If Dezmelda is raising a potential challenger
to the all-male hierarchy that Blackwood is
forming at the Church of Night, it adds some
interest to this future plotline as she may
use the baby girl as a means of getting revenge
for her past mistreatment by the Church.
Remember that Letitia is Blackwood's first-born
and therefore the rightful heir to lead the
Church over Judas.
However, Blackwood thinks Judas is his only
child after Zelda decided to keep Letitia's
birth a secret from him as she feared for
the baby girl's safety.
Sabrina's mother Diana made a special appearance
in the holiday episode and gave us what seem
to be a few revelations about why she's been
stuck in Limbo.
When Sabrina speaks to her toward the end
of the episode, Diana seems to be saying that
she was worried about whether Sabrina was
being taken care of.
Now that Diana can see that Sabrina has a
loving family who watch over her, the implication
seems to be that she may now be able to pass
on from Limbo.
However, I suspect we will see more of Diana
even if it's only in flashbacks.
I also wonder whether there's a chance any
of her appearances were a trick by Ms Wardwell.
It's just a possible theory, but when Diana
first appeared during the séance and Sabrina
asked her about why she was stuck in Limbo,
the message relayed back was "not safe".
I don't know if she was just referring to
the spirits of the Yuletide Lads who were
invading the Spellman residence or if she
was alluding to something else.
The other suspicious thing is that the proof
Diana offered up to Sabrina that she really
was her mum was just her flight number which
is something that could be easily known by
someone nefarious who conspired to cause the
plane accident or at least knew about it.
Something we also discover is that Diana learned
some spells from her husband Edward which
is how she taught Sabrina the changeling trick
she performed on Gryla.
However, Diana warns Sabrina that while she
herself followed Edward down the Path of Night,
she wouldn't recommend that to any other mortals,
which has implications for Brina's relationship
with Harvey.
At the end of "A Midwinter's Tale", Harvey
gives back to Brina the magic pencils she
gifted him and he asks her never to use magic
around or on him again.
It's an uncomfortable moment for the pair,
so I'm curious as to how in Season 2 we'll
see the two of them back together again, given
what we saw teased in the trailer for Part
2?
And will Sabrina actually keep her tacit agreement
not to use any magic on Harvey again?
One thing we do know that is pretty likely
from the way this episode ends and the teases
from the Season 2 trailer is that we'll be
getting more emphasis on the love triangle
set up between Sabrina, Nick and Harvey.
Although "A Midwinter's Tale" wraps up quite
nicely, it wouldn't be Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina without the tease of something
much more sinister for Season 2!
"Oh and now all we have to do is get through
Witch Epiphany in one piece without, er, some
other terror rising from the bowels of Hell."
The Witch's Epiphany that Hilda is referring
to is likely the coven's version of the Christian
feast day of the Epiphany which takes place
on the 6th of January and is also known as
Three Kings' Day.
Although Hilda's semi-joking, it looks like
her fears are being realised as the episode
closes with three demon kings emerging from
the entrance of a Greendale mine.
In the traditional story of Christmas, three
kings or wise men travelled to visit Jesus
after his birth, bearing gifts of frankincense,
myrrh and gold.
The arrival of these three demonic-looking
kings in Greendale could be related to the
recent birth of Father Blackwood's son Judas
and I wonder if they are bringing gifts from
Hell or the Devil for the little baby boy?
Apparently, the title of the Part 2 premiere
will be "The Epiphany" so I imagine we'll
find out then.
Another possibility is that the three kings'
arrival is to greet the birth of an antichrist-type
figure.
It might just be a coincidence, but it's curious
that Nick Scratch was conveniently away visiting
the "unholy lands" during the episode and
I've talked previously about Nick's possible
darker side as "Old Nick" and "Old Scratch"
are both nicknames for the Devil.
The arrival of these three kings may also
be related to an interesting scene which appeared
in the trailer for the holiday special but
which never actually made it into the episode.
In the trailer, there's a shot of Sabrina's
father Edward appearing to offer up a baby
to the Dark Lord.
And crucially, in the background is what looks
like a nativity scene – the type you might
see in some Christian churches over Christmas
time.
If that is a nativity scene behind Sabrina,
do the Three Demon Kings have something to
do with what's going on in this scene?
What's especially interesting is why this
scene was teased in the trailer but then never
appeared in the episode.
Was it deleted or is it something that's going
to happen in a future episode of Season 2,
for example the premiere?
Looking a bit more closely at what's going
on, I suspect this scene is a vision or dream
that Sabrina is having because she's wearing
a nightie and she isn't wearing her usual
black hair-band.
And I think it also relates back to that vision
Sabrina had in the very first episode of the
series where she saw her parents with a baby
in the woods and then she discovered a second
baby with cloven hooves.
The baby that Edward is showing to the Dark
Lord is also wrapped in the same white crocheted
fabric from Sabrina's Season 1 vision.
Could this be another hint to an evil twin
for Sabrina in Season 2?
If you want to know more about that, then
tap the card here for my other video where
I explain why Sabrina may have an evil twin
who she's yet to meet.
I'll also add a link below in the video description
and at the end of this video.
Fans of Michelle Gomez didn't get an awful
lot of the wicked demoness in the special
episode, but we do know that she still hasn't
received the promotion she was hoping for
from the Dark Lord.
Obviously, she has plenty of trouble planned
for Sabrina in Season 2 and by the end of
this episode, in a deliciously wicked moment,
she takes a gingerbread version of Sabrina
and bites the head off, hinting at more voodoo
havoc in Season 2 which we also saw teased
in the Part 2 trailer.
In an interview with EW, showrunner Roberto
Aguirre-Sacasa has also revealed that, although
Dr Cerberus didn't show up in this episode,
we're definitely going to find out what "secrets"
the bookstore owner "is keeping from [Aunt]
Hilda" in Part 2.
I suspect Aguirre-Sacasa may be hinting at
Dr Cerberus's possible werewolf form teased
in the Season 2 trailer.
Remember that in Season 1, Dr Cerberus said
that he's the oldest of three brothers; and,
interestingly, in Greek mythology, Cerberus
is a multi-headed dog who keeps watch over
the gates to the Underworld.
Now, my question for you is do you think we'll
see more of Sabrina's mum Diana in Season
2?
Let me know your thoughts and any other ideas
in the comments below.
Tap left for the Sabrina Evil Twin theory
or tap right for another Sabrina video you're
sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Congratulations to the winner of my Fantastic
Beasts giveaway.
Make sure you contact me so I can send you
the prize.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!